all right it's being
division three will is uh is going to go
into session we have nine bills to to
talk about today
uh we we heard um a lot about eight of
them last week and so there's one new
one today that we're gonna hold off to
the end
hb
1647. if you're here only for that bill
i wouldn't worry too much i think we're
going to move fairly quickly through
the other eight bills
it might take an hour though to get
there
i want to welcome representative woods
and representative weber who are coming
over from hhs to replace a couple of
division three members that were not
able to be here today representative
nordgren
and
representative rogers
so um so with that
we're in session
and our first bill
is
1604 including the state medical
facilities and statute providing medical
freedom immunizations in immunizations
there's an amendment on this
that
i think comports to our conversation
on wednesday
has
i assume not everyone in the committee
has had an opportunity to look at 1604
the amendment is that right
representative weber representative
woods
right right right and you you didn't
benefit from last week's conversation so
i'll give you a moment to look over it
um
can you point out what's changed i i
will i didn't want to talk while they're
reading
you ready okay
so so what this amendment uh attempted
to do and and i think it has um
substantially done and if not completely
is
um the
area of religious exemption
was
a little quiet
in terms of what was needed
by the employer to evaluate whether or
not they've got a good religious
exemption document
and so
this this basically
spells out how the employer is to
evaluate the religious exemption
largely it says
that they
have more of a bureaucratic function
than to sit in judgment
i think that's because we wanted to
honor the prime sponsors
thought
and the house vote that um
it's it's uh
real since since the government is here
to protect religious freedom
it it doesn't seem appropriate for the
government to mandate um
an employer
to oversee and evaluate the religious
beliefs of an employee so
their role has been limited to
evaluating the completeness of the
paperwork process
they they do have the ability to deny
one if they believe that there
is a is compelling evidence of some kind
of a fraud
so so that's that's what that amendment
did is there any discussion on it
represent weber you have a question
no i just say thank you mr chairman um
it looks to me like
um
from a quick reading that it's simply
explains more carefully what the
procedure is going to be and therefore
is not
a particular change over anything that
we've already seen thank you
that that was our intent and that's
certainly what i hope happened with this
i think it has is there are there any
other
questions or comments um because if not
i'd take a motion to con vote on the
amendment yes representative weiler
have we looked at what the form looks
like that they have to fill out remember
there was one that was being distributed
that was very
uh complete and and they wanted all
sorts of information about the person
where do you go to church how often do
you go who is your leader and all this
kind of thing that was one of that
i think that's a fair question and i
believe it's it's answered and uh
maybe it'll satisfy you um it says that
the exemption shall simply state which
to me means this is what it will state
i insert the requester's name hereby
attest that i sincerely hold religious
beliefs and or engage in religious
practice or observe observances
that dictate the refusal to accept the
required vaccination
and then the signature is there with
along with the date there there aren't
any other questions that could be
extraneous like which church do you go
to
i moved the amendment
is there a second
second
seconded by representative bean
so we're going to conduct a role a roll
call vote on whether we accept amendment
2022-1160
[Music]
as an amendment to
house bill 1604-fn
mr clerk would you call the role
yes
chairman edwards yes
so i think
that's seven to nothing uh and we'll
send that to the uh full finance
committee for review on wednesday
is there a volunteer to write
the committee report often referred to
as a blurb
representative wyler will write the
committee report
and of course it's just a draft so that
uh it's it's quick and easy processing
depending on how the committee votes on
wednesday it's i don't think we need a
committee report coming out of division
yes
sir
the the next vote is on
1608 as we just amended
oh excuse me
1604 i already switched pages
representative walner has a question
[Music]
um
all right
thank you for the heads up
yes
represent walden
no
so on a four to three vote we'll pass
that to um the full committee and that
and that's the one you'll be writing a
draft blurb for
okay so now we're going to
relative to withdrawal from the state
immunization registry is there is there
an amendment that we submitted on this
one
i need i'm checking my own notes in case
you're wondering what i'm doing
if i could there's no amendment on that
one and that was one of the bills that
as amended by the house doesn't have a
fiscal impact anymore
all right so the guidance on this is
when it doesn't have a fiscal impact
that
we we do a blurb that essentially says
this has no fiscal impact and therefore
we're returning it to the um
full house
and then that is an example of if
finance accepts that then it can go on
to the consent calendar if there's no
objective objection
so um
so i i think we've had the discussion
around 1608 and
i i would entertain a motion
to
recommend an otp with the uh blurb that
basically says no fiscal impact
therefore we have no
removed
it's moved by representative irf is it
our second
seconded by representative walner
uh mr clerk would you call us
uh this we're gonna we're the motion is
otp
uh and then and then the blurb basically
uh explains it to the whole house that
there was no fiscal impact and therefore
the finance committee has not taken a
position on it other than to reflect the
policy vote yes representative
and i will just note that this one was
unanimous coming out of our committee as
well so
more proof that great minds think alike
so uh
mr clerk would you
conduct a roll call on 1608 with an otp
motion
yes
uh thank you that vote is seven to zero
um
we'll move on to 1662.
uh we discussed this last week as well
and uh and we drafted an amendment for
this that is uh
if you don't have it
you will get you a copy it's 2022-1
and the point of this was to
to do two things
the first thing is on lines three
through four and it's simply a
clarification that the
privacy impact assessments which is a
written risk assessment and mitigation
plan
that that is for each it system
and not just um
for the department overall
so on line three it says for each it
system that that that's a key one
and then the other was that the
department had done a a better analysis
of the personnel and
said that we should
change it to a labor grade 30.
and so you'll see on line 21 grade 30 is
cited and then the financial impact is
adjusted based on that grade change
so that's what this amendment does is
there is there any discussion on the
amendment
i'm not i'm not seeing any anyone
interested in discussing the amendment
um so i'll move the amendment you'll
move the amendment is there a second
second
seconded by the clerk
um would you please conduct a roll call
on whether or not we well i guess we
could
is i've seen this before you just a show
of hands on the amendment and then a
roll call on yeah okay let's do that so
uh show of hands if you are in favor of
accepting amendment 1662
uh
that is numbered 1134 please raise your
hands
okay that's everyone so now um so now
the
vote the roll call vote is on 1662
as amended by amendment 1134
yes
and chairman edwards yes
okay uh i i'll volunteer to write the
blurb on this
okay so now we're on to
uh hb 1609
[Music]
relative to the scope of the fetal
protection act
um i don't there is not an amendment to
consider so this is uh the bill as we
discussed last week
um
is there any
i i don't want to redo the whole
conversation from last week but uh i
don't want to shut down debate either so
does anyone have a a comment that they
or a question that they want to address
on 1609
rep
representative weber and then
representative walner
thank you mr chairman i would just point
out that there isn't any fiscal impact
again this is again one that has no
fiscal impact and it has been passed by
both the
policy committee and the house so i
would hope that the recommendation would
be ought to pass
with the attendant blurb explaining that
there is no
fiscal impact uh representative
did you
okay so um there is a tiny amount of a
fiscal impact but as we discussed last
monday
uh it's my view and a view i've
coordinated with um
the
finance chair that
the discussions and agreements around
hb2
required a particular
crafting of what went into hb2
as part of what we did to make sure that
there was enough agreement that we got
the total budget passed
and that was kind of a nice milestone
because the prior two terms a budget did
not get passed and so we we essentially
got it done
so so because 1609
addresses
an issue that was so fundamental to
getting uh the support necessary for the
state to pass a budget
i i do see a very significant fiscal
impact here that isn't shown in the in
the methodology
and and i'm just concerned
if um we basically go back on our word
that we made less than a year ago when
we're needing to negotiate
the next budget
whether the republicans or democrats are
in charge it's still an issue of
credibility within the finance committee
if if we make an agreement will we hold
to the agreement and
i i want to say yes we will
and and that's that's what i think is
the rationale
for
um
are taking a a stance on 1609 as uh as
it got amended
so i do do you have
uh representative
well you and i have a difference of
opinion about this i i feel like there's
often in budgets
that we've passed in the
past in the past and probably will in
the future
there are things that are in budgets at
the time that we pass them
that in the two-year cycle do end up
because there's more information because
programs
or policies don't work out the way
people thought they would that we
changed them during the two-year cycle
so i
i don't agree with
that as if we
if we lived by that what it would mean
is that we would never change anything
in a two-year cycle because we promised
that the budget would look the way
we passed it on whatever it was
june of
20.
no 21. sorry sorry about that um that we
would nothing would change in that
during the whole two years so
um
i i think it's not really a
good argument for it being a financial
implication
all right i i can accept your argument
as being a valid and
faithfully held argument
having been in the midst of the storm
i know there were about three
major agreements that were critical
and one of them was fmli for example
that's what was necessary to make sure
the governor was on board and that's why
i voted for the repeal of fmli is
because i made a promise to the governor
and so this because of the criticality
of this to the agreement
i i'm going to vote to itl um
is there any other discussion
may i have a motion move itl
some moved by representative irf
seconded by representative weiler would
you conduct the vote please
yes
4 3 itl um
oh
i'll write the blurb for this one as
well
okay so we're on to 16
i'm hearing some discussion
is there a discussion
okay so i don't think we
formally write committee reports out of
the division i i'm i'm wanting to get it
done in advance
so so that it's
thank you wrong
thank you do you know who's going to be
accountable
okay representative walner accountable
for the minority report
okay uh hb 1622 relative to notice that
a health care provider is no longer
accepting new patients in relative to
mental health parity
we do have an amendment on this one
[Music]
no there's no amendment on this one
no
there is no amendment on this one
and this was another bill that
the fiscal note currently reads that hhs
thinks there may be a small fiscal
impact but based on the department's
testimony last week there won't actually
be one so the fiscal note will be
revised accordingly
all right so i i think this hues to the
argument that we should just pass otp
based on the policy
committee's vote in the whole house
since it does not have a fiscal impact
and we've already written a blurb
that'll say substantially that we can
just repurpose the blurb if
if
we end up deciding to otp on this
is is there is there any discussion
anyone wants to engage in on 1622
relative to mental health parity
move otp uh there we have a motion to
otp is that seconded
seconded by the clerk
when you're ready mr clerk would you
call a roll call
um
yes
chairman edward yes
mr chairman the vote 7-0
okay thank thank you uh with a vote on
that uh in
agreeing that
is there any disagreement that we can
just repurpose the blurb
no no so we'll just go with the same
blurb that we used before
uh yes
so um
now we're on to 1642.
representative walner has crafted an
amendment on this
um would you explain your amendment to
us
it'll take me a few years to using the
mic
um
this was the bill about um
the results of lead testing
be included on
the health form that schools and
child care providers
receive on children and as we talked
about it last
time which was
a couple of weeks ago we talked about
that we did not
want to see
children denied access to care
because um
they had not
either the form was not filled in with
the lead levels
testing
on it or
they had not had it the idea was to this
is to incent to get parents to do the
work but not to deny children in their
access to child care
or um to school so the amendment which
is
11 59 h is that right kevin
yep
yes
actually says um
the health form shall include
at least one result of blood level
testing required under rsa 130-a
colon 5
a
or
rsa-130-a5
colon
c a child shall not be removed from or
denied entry to child care facilities
due to lack of blood lead
level test
so i
then
my reasoning on it is it is
certainly
it is certainly policy
but for families it certainly is a
financial has fam
real serious financial ramifications
if they can't access child care or if
they
have to be in child care and have their
child removed so
all right thank you for that uh
mr ripple i i think this may be
a bill in which the fiscal note was to
be amended because the one that we have
before us still says that the insurance
department states that in order to meet
the bill's requirements it'll hire three
full-time positions could you could you
straighten us out on where we're at on
the fiscal note please
i think the fiscal note for this one
suggested that the only impact might be
to local school districts
and based on what we heard last week the
form
already includes the information being
requested so there won't actually be a
fiscal impact
okay so
what i think i just heard you say and
i'm looking for clarity is that the
fiscal note needs to be
uh amended and that the request for
three full-time positions removed
i think the request for three positions
was on a different bill uh bill that
you've already voted on but yes the
fiscal note for this bill will be
revised to say no impact
all right just
for those playing at home
the the bill hb 1622 is introduced
on on page
three where the
fiscal note picks up the second
paragraph
does say the insurance department states
that uh in order to meet the
requirements it'll need to hire three
full-time positions
each starting at july 1
2022 the estimated costs are as follows
and then there's a table that shows
salaries but it doesn't look like that's
would cover three full-time employees
so so
just give me one more moment
and then it also goes on to say the
department states that the bill's impact
on insurance premium tax revenue if any
is indeterminable so so i do see a
fiscal note representative webber
i believe the fiscal note dates from the
original bill which had um a reporting
requirement uh for the schools and that
and
and they had to report i believe to dhhs
which is why
there was a significant concern
and that was taken out in committee if i
am recalling correctly and
representative woods can
correct me if i'm wrong on that
but i will i will also state while i've
got the microphone that
um
the
amendment proposed by representative
walner does certainly represent the
intent of the committee which was to
create more ways of incentivizing
checking the levels for kids and making
sure that that happened but it was never
the intent of the committee that a child
not be
allowed to continue at school
we were considering the health aspects
and perhaps not quite as clear as we
should have been on the
the school aspects but it was we don't
we didn't
want
removal from school to be a a
consequence
all right i think uh representative
canark when he was standing in for hhs
last week
did make that point which is why the
amendment got crafted as it did i i just
uh
i i looked to the lba to be the official
arbiter on the status of fiscal notes
and i just want before the fiscal
committee or the finance committee votes
that we know what the fiscal note is
going to say yep and it'll say no impact
and i just want to clarify for the
record i think some of these bills have
similar numbers 1622 was relative to
mental health parity i think that one
had the original cost 1642 didn't have
the positions
and
it did originally have a fiscal note but
we've since amended it
um
to say the only impact will be to locals
and we'll amend that again to say no
cost at all
okay so i i'll i'll take you at your
word you know what you're you're doing
so to the state
i think we can vote assuming that there
is no state cost to doing this
um but that we are adding an enforcement
cost at an indeterminable level to the
local schools because we're asking them
to do more and we're not sending them
any money to do it
so
i will be voting
i like the amendment so i'll vote for
the amendment but i intend to vote
against 1622
because i think it violates uh article
28 a which is our no
unfunded mandate rule if if we want to
come back and amendment amend this in
the in the full finance committee to pay
for it uh so that the schools aren't
just doing more with less
i would or at least more with the same i
i
i think that would be good but i don't
have that amendment today
so i'm looking for a
show of hands
is there any other discussion
oh i'm looking for a show of hands on uh
representative walner's amendment uh
okay and then mr clerk if you'll take a
roll call on
1622 i guess we're waiting in uh motion
i i'm i'm i'm looking for a motion to
itl by representative verve is there a
second
seconded by representative bean
when you're ready mr clerk please take
the vote
[Music]
yes
no
all right so we send forward an itl
recommendation to the committee uh after
uh accepting the amendment
um
who who wants to write this one
i'm looking at our vice chair do you
want to write a blurb on this
it's either you or representative woods
all right
okay uh i and i just want to i just want
to say for the record who's here raise
your hand if you're here from the
department
i got one two i got i got two folks so
this is the other thing that i want to
say about this bill
this is great we want our kids tested
for lead i voted for the requirement
that our kids get tested
early before
daycare and then before schools i voted
for that i'm i want the testing
philosophically i'm opposed to this
because i don't want the legislature to
lean on the school system to be our
enforcer i think that messes up the
relationship of an educator to the
parents and to the family and so what i
would encourage the the department to do
is to develop with others
a public health education program so
that
you know we're out of covid now so all
the coveted reasons for not going and
getting it done those are should be
behind us let's educate our parents to
let them know why this is such a great
idea we don't wear seat belts
or we don't have a seatbelt law and we
wear our seat belts more than they do in
massachusetts it's we'll do rational
things if we understand why it's
rational so if we
you know i'm not opposed to lead testing
it needs to be done we just i just want
to make sure that we're doing it with
respect to
our citizens so
thank you
so with that i think we're on
i have a
15 26
this is
[Music]
relative to income eligibility for in
and out
and
i have an amendment to introduce to this
um
[Music]
if we accepted everything and the
amendment number is 1121 by the way
if we accepted everything that was in
the
in the bill as it came over to us 1526
this amendment does that too
also
what what it does that's different
though is
instead of funding the entire
year that begins uh july 1
so in a few months and going for a full
year
what it does is it just funds the last
quarter
of the next year okay so so it'll still
be in this budget it's a change to this
budget
but it's only for
three months instead of 12 months
so what was the thinking behind that the
thinking behind that
was that
we
once the budget's in we should try not
to affect it unless it's really
important and this is really important
so i'm i'm okay with affecting it
somewhat but not for the full year
um i i've gotten the support of the
finance chair and the speaker to support
one quarter of a year instead of the
full thing if we approve this as a house
and the senate accepts
it will become law before
the governor's budget process starts
and so what that will enable them to do
is to go ahead
and anticipate this program being in
place for the full year or the full
budget cycle in the next budget
so that they can do the analysis and
give us the the total budget cost then
so
what what i'm asking you to do
because i would have to vote itl on 1526
without this amendment what i'm asking
you to do
is to accept
amendment 1121 which
allows 1526 to go over to the senate if
finance agrees with us
but with funding just one quarter of the
year instead of the full 12 months
so is there any conversation on that
representative walner
well i would have much preferred us to
have
funded it for the full year
and considering that our revenues are
coming in
at a very very good pace
it seems like
we could do a little bit better for this
i would love to see us
be able to come in at least for half a
year
but i think the
important piece is that we get it in
place
and have it ongoing and in the next
budget
and um i will vote against the amendment
but i will vote for the bill
is there any other conversation
so so representative allner uh thank you
and um if you were to bring
an amendment
uh to the full finance committee uh in
two days uh i think that would be a
great topic of conversation
i will do that thank you thank you
okay um so with that
uh we're going to do a show hands on
amendment 11 21.
opposed
well
now
opposed did you guys
so
so the amendment is accepted uh four to
three
and now we can take a roll call vote on
1526 as we just now amended it
so moved
second
earth
thank you you can conduct a roll call
when you're ready
yes
thank you
okay so uh with that
we can move on to
um house bill 1531
repealing certain statutory commissions
relating to children
and
i'll go first to mr ripple
to verify my understanding my
understanding is an updated fiscal note
would indicate that this has no fiscal
impact is that correct that's correct
okay so uh it it feels to me that we
ought to do what we've done on two prior
bills where we uh pass it otp onto the
full finance committee with the
the blurb essentially saying the same
thing we've said which is no fiscal
impact therefore we're just passing the
uh bill back to the house and uh i i
believe the finance chair would want to
put it on consent at that point
is there any discussion
uh it's been moved otp
is there a second
seconded by representative bean
mr clerk when you're ready would you
please conduct a roll call
three
yes
okay so 1531
passes 7-0
otp
which brings us to 1647.
this is a bill that representative
abrami wanted to talk to us on he's
across the hall
he said there was another person here
that would be
also talking to him
talking for us or to us and there's
representative abrami right on schedule
thank you sir for joining us
yeah so so we just we just opened on
1647.
you you can tell us whatever you'd like
about your bill
appreciate it and uh unfortunately i'm
gonna have to as soon as i'm done and
then i'm gonna ask that you
entertain brenda town who
who knows more about this than than i do
okay that's the good place to ask the
questions with brenda
so
i um
i filed this bill because i um as the
prime sponsor
because i instinctively know joint
consider children
of divorced parents is best for the
children and society as a whole
today's
child support
approach is out of sync with
joint parenting
so let's say one parent has 45 percent
the parenting and the other has 55
there are many cases where
where
the woman 45 gets zero
child support and the other gets 100
percent it's not right
now this state has been dealing with
this for years no it's been a problem
for many years
in in 2018 this finance committee
funded a five hundred thousand
dollar research uh report and it was
done by the carsey uh center
and that report gave many
recommendations i mean obviously we
spent five hundred thousand on this as a
state
something's broken for us to do that and
and this bill
reflects many of the recommendations
that were in that report
now in 2020
there was a supreme court case anderson
versus anderson
which
which they refused to take well they
took but then they said wait a minute
we're tired of this we're tired of all
these cases from lower courts coming to
us
because we don't define
we need to define
child support better
than we do
and
and they said fix it
now i was in this position a couple of
years ago
when
when we had the issue of how towns were
assessing
utility properties
we got a formula
i said has chaired that commission
i said it's got to be a simple formula
that's what we got and we passed it and
that was a 40-year problem that we
solved this is similar we got a problem
that's been around a long long time
and we need we needed to fix it and this
bill does just that
so and it passed out of uh children and
family law
if it passed on the floor
so there's two things you're probably
going to hear after yeah brenda there
may be others testifying about
wow some are going to say well this is
going to create more caucasian court
cases i i beg to differ on that
why why
we have we have examples vermont has
been doing this exact language we have
or not exact language but the similar
kind of a formula
that they're using and they found that
their court cases reduced over time
significantly
we got some more data from kentucky
who's has this law
implemented for for a while now a
similar law
uh and that
those court cases reduced by eleven
percent
but i think the other thing that
finance has to look at because i'm
trying i was trying to initially trying
to figure out why it came to finance
a number
it has to it
has to do with
something called a self-support reserve
and that got increased in the bill
because carsey center said you should do
this
raised
raised this allowance from 115 to 120
percent of federal poverty level
and
and there may be
some issue with public funding that
might be lost
uh because of that but brenda understood
been the town understands this much
better than i do
and i know she's going to be addressing
this
but i think
i i i
the numbers aren't going to be that
great
if that happens a matter of fact in the
fiscal note it says indeterminable i
know we get a lot of that indeterminable
we get that in ways and means too
uh but i i don't think it's going to be
because the the the increase only goes
from fourteen thousand eight hundred and
twelve dollars
to fifteen thousand four hundred and
fifty six dollars which is not a big big
increase
120 percent again it's in the fiscal
note it should be
um
i i think it's also in the fiscal note
the fiscal note is in the asm no the
bill wasn't
i don't know
so give good consideration to this
and and uh miss town can uh explain this
a lot better than i can
there's one question i'd like to ask you
sure uh in your testimony you said that
you think that the
litigation
if we pass this would decrease
the fiscal note says um the opposite the
judicial branch states that the bill
will likely result in additional
litigation in certain instances in which
child support would be reduced by the
new guidelines
so
why why do you think they've got it
wrong
i don't know we got we got
we we heard from other states that that
that's not what happened
all right and then i noticed that
uh your next speaker has an answer yeah
is there are there any questions for
representative abram who wants to get
back into his hearing
i have a question well my question is
it seems that this is reducing
child support the way i read things and
i don't understand
how that makes sense and is helpful to
the children
no but well
it
it reallocates how the child support is
given to each parent
with because this is about
then this bill doesn't impact that it's
about the joint parenting and the amount
of time that each each parent has the
child
and again
ms town will can explain that uh better
than i can again so if if i if i hear
that right and check my interpretation
that in the the joint parenting scenario
the amount of the child support will
stay the same this formula just
clarifies which parents should be paying
how much of that same total exactly all
right thank you uh representative did
you have a question and representative
abram can decide if he wants to field it
i'm just trying to follow that oh
the conversation and
if my so it will reduce
or it has the potential to reduce
the um child support for one parent
i'd rather have
it better that she answered the question
because she knows this inside and out
and i don't want to give the wrong
answer okay okay
and plus they're holding they're waiting
for me and they were dealing with the
marijuana bill right now
i don't want to keep you from your pot
so
uh
well you're you thank you so much for
coming by appreciate it
and and then
do you two want to come up because it
looks like you both had
interest in answering questions
you're welcome to join her at the table
if you if you think you might
you have to press until you see red up
here
there
there you go so thank you very much for
allowing me to speak um pat and i have
been working on some family court issues
for the past couple years we need you to
start by an introduction the careful
slow spelling of your last name and the
organization you represent
so my name is brenda towne t-o-w-n-e
and i am just a concerned parent
grandparent
historically i led a 5 000 person
parents group here in new hampshire
and today i am following through with
some of my commitments to those folks
that we would try to remedy
some of the challenges in family court
so
in the gentleman's name
my name is michael last name is dinan
d-i-n-a-n
dynan
and i'm a father of two young ladies uh
from the portsmouth area
so so you're not representing an
organization i am not i'm all right very
good we're happy to hear what
you have to say in this town
thank you very much i'm going to give
you a little bit of history because i
think that will level set why we're here
so back in 2015
the
legislator her legislature heard a bill
to move new hampshire to the vermont
calculations which are embedded in this
bill
it was decided at that point in time in
2016 to change that bill effort for the
state of new hampshire
using the cars to evaluate the practices
of new hampshire
and make recommended
nations over the course of their work
they interviewed judges
lawyers dhhs
and gals and then they went through
court records through our own
courthouses to identify
what was happening what they found is
that in 80 sorry 80 percent of modified
child support orders they were modified
because of shared parenting time
so the judges
along with judge ashley who is
interviewed personally by me and also by
representative berrion
also came through with a very similar
recommendation and that was for
standardized
child support calculations to limit the
amount of litigation
between
parents because this would be calculated
and easy for them to follow as well as
it stopped the arbitrage between judges
because they're fun they were finding it
difficult to get consistent judgments
across the different
courthouses
in
2019 um so in 2018 this report was
complete and it was presented to the
child and family law during that time
and in that court in that report there
were multiple recommendations that this
bill
is a reflection of
now simultaneously the state of new
hampshire had litigation at the supreme
court level in a case called silva v
silva
in the case of silva v silva in 2019 our
supreme court
interpreted using the webster's
definition of fixed cost our current
rsas and in their judgment they made it
impossible to change a child support
order based on parenting time
based on
the interpretation of fixed costs that
the higher earner would have to reduce
the fixed cost such as mortgage payments
of the other parent so since that point
in time new hampshire
judges have had their hands tied in
modifying child support to support
parents who manage their children
equally or near equally across
households
now
pat
representative abrami did mention
anderson v anderson because that did
follow soon thereafter our own legislate
our own supreme court kicked this back
and said guys we need a law on how to
split child support because there is
none on the books
so that is what has led us here the
kharsi report again all of that
investment of time and effort brought
forward these recommendations and again
included the input of our dhhs as well
as
our our bar association members
so we also have
now your fiscal note concerns and so i
wanted to address those in my feedback
so as pat mentioned the first issue was
that reserve
the reserve of a parent who has to pay
child support today in the state of new
hampshire
okay while you're in there on the
reserve i i don't know what that is i
don't we don't handle this so if you
could i'll explain it to you so what
happens is when a parent comes in and
they're a low-income earner the
child support calculation says you know
you're you're only making income to a
hundred and fifteen percent of poverty
line so again in our fiscal notes it's
like about fourteen thousand five
hundred a year
the currency school looked at that and
when they uh did our evaluation
they recognized that that reserve was
too low they wanted to raise it and what
that reserve does is if a parent makes
that number or less they pay 50 a month
in child support because they can't
support themselves
so what we're recommending just
identical to what carsey did is that we
need that one parent to have their
income raised to 120
of poverty in order to be able to pay
their fifty dollars a month in child
support if they're making you know that
amount of money otherwise they fall into
a condition where they would allocate
child support in our standard
calculations make sense
how do we raise that income to the
parent
well i'd love to just go to a different
group of parents well what we're doing
is we're comparing it to what they're
submitting on their financial affidavits
so whatever that parent is making that's
used as the basis for calculating what
the child support would be and so if
they make under that 120 percent of
poverty line
which is what's in this bill
versus the hundred and fifteen percent
that we've had historically they would
pay fifty dollars a month in child
support
no they have to pay 50 a month in child
no what we want to do is we want to
raise that number so that it would be
120 percent of the poverty line and then
that rule would apply to those people
they would pay 50 a month instead of
being allocated a percent so
for example if you have one child in the
state of new hampshire and you're a
higher earner you typically pay about 22
of your income in child support so this
protects the people that make less than
120 of the poverty line that they would
only pay 50 a month instead of having
that percentage allocated against their
income
mr dinan did you have something to add
to all that
in that one portion of it yes i mean
that requires that still a minimum of
fifty dollars would be paid i i think
this is a small part of it and it's
because this is one of the financial
concerns that regards the finance
through three committee the other one is
the impact to the courts and that's i
will let you start on that first yeah
because
and that 50 would be a minimum required
of anyone not making up to 120 of the
uh
well
mr chair yes
yes go ahead wait wait a second
representative i just like to correct
the record here as amended it's 150
percent not 120 so just
we should be using accurate numbers
i i'm sorry i have the um methodology of
the original bill here in front of me
and it's 120 it went from 150 the bill
was amended so so could you i this is an
important point would you just stick our
nose on the page and line number you're
referring to
there's an amended
um
i'm trying to find it here there's an
amended fiscal motive i'm not mistaken
mr ripple
there's there is an amended fiscal note
uh which you should all have dated march
15th if you're looking at the bill
itself on page 3 line 13
is the increase from 115 to 150.
okay okay so the uh earlier okay
references
the earlier references when you
mentioned 120
would you agree that you meant to say
150 yes i didn't realize the amendment
had hit but yeah so the person's making
twenty thousand dollars a year
is what the the fiscal note shows okay
twenty thousand eight forty two thank
you for the catch there representative
and just so we understand this what that
means is anybody who makes that much or
less
pays a fixed a small fixed amount
fixed amount that's the 50
as opposed to looking at the tables
which are also included in the bill
which determine percentages based on
income that you pay as your portion of
child support
so essentially it decreases
the required child support of that
parent
so i i i wanted to let you finish before
we we went into all the questions
do you feel like you're ready i i i
think there's three sections that you
want to address in here but i don't i
think it is prudent to answer as we go
through if there's questions on the
three different independents
so in reality we're talking not raising
the
income of a parent that's not making
much but with going to a different
criteria which may let that parent out
if that parent's making 115 120
they're not paying anything
they're paying 50 dollars they're paying
50 until they get down to what
so that so anything under that threshold
they're paying 50 a month even if
they're making 200 bucks a month right
okay i guess that's not the way i
understood from where you thank you
thank you
okay all right i i have some clarifying
questions but is are there any other
questions at this point
okay so
so i
fortunately this first time i've ever
had to deal with child support issues
god bless you uh
i started i'll get back to you um
so
the two big things in my head going into
this
is
what is the impact on the total amount
of child support that gets paid to take
care of the child it does it go up stay
the same or go down it sounds like it it
may go down under some scenarios of
joint parenting i i want you to clarify
that and then the other part while
you're talking to that though is
connected
is is what happens
uh relative to the state's obligations
do does the amount that the state
contributes in
uh
tanf or anything else does that is that
is that affected by this bill and if so
how much
okay so i'll start by get walking
through the calculation so that we can
level set
so what this bill does is it considers
the fact that parents are parenting
their kids in two separate households
with nearly equivalent parenting time
and so because of that the expenses of
having two households are actually
higher so what it does is it raises up
the total
child support
costs because you've got two households
and then what it does is it allocates
based on income the percentage of that
obligation how it would fall into each
house
and then it gives a credit for the
amount of time that you're parenting
your children
so you raise the overall
cost profile recognizing that there's
two households
and then if parent number one has forty
percent of the time and the other parent
has sixty percent
um if they were making exactly the same
amount of income you know a credit of
only 40 of the parenting time would be
given to one parent and they would pay
the incremental 20 to the other parent
to make up the difference and then it
also as i said considers income
variability the income would be leveled
between households
that's a great explanation and then
could we just get like yes or no
is the amount that the state pays
affected at all by the way these
calculations take place well i would
tell you that the what would affect the
state would be the matching federal
funds for title 4-d
today new hampshire is the third highest
child support ordered
state in the country
by almost
40 percent over the median and that has
occurred
especially over the past few years with
our court's inability to
allocate parenting time as a factor in
determining the child support order
so in effect our overall child support
orders will decline because now we're
righting a wrong all right
so that the matching funds from the
federal government may in fact decline
in our title for dematching
but it needs to be cleared those are
only funds that go through the state i'm
sorry yes those are only for funds paid
from the higher earner to the lower
earner that go through the state the
majority of the funds that are paid and
which would all of them would be
affected by this are paid directly such
as i don't pay to the states the title
4d doesn't benefit or not benefit from
from what i pay that is only for
payments that go through the state yes
and just wanted to make a quick point
about this what happened with silva v
silva and i've it's taken me about three
years to get understanding of this
because i've suffered it myself and
lived this every day
is that the higher earner pays the lower
earner the total amount of funds that
would have been available
for
to be shared across two households you
can use the word spread across two
households but what silva b silva did
because of the fixed cost issue and then
also another thing when this went to the
supreme court is it said um
equal or approximately equal parenting
time is not a grounds for an adjustment
so what that did we all heard anderson v
anderson that statement and what the
judge said in anderson v anderson he
said it's not my job to make the laws i
enforce them go to your legislatures and
in fact he said that go to your
legislature so we now have the third
highest amount of child support paid in
the country we were a national parenting
organization gave us an f
um and it's because we don't have the
offset method we most states vermont
what 1467 would do excuse me 1647 would
do is allow the higher earner to pay the
lower the lower earner pays the higher
basically the delta between the two
currently in in which is very clear to
me understanding about this
it's not going to change the amount of
funds paid it's going to
change how they're allocated so
currently because of silva v silva all
the funds from the higher earner are
paid to the lower earner in any
situation if the lower earner makes just
a dollar annual income or a dollar less
than the higher earner all those funds
go to the low earner if someone made
fifty thousand dollars and the higher
owner makes
fifty thousand in one dollar all of
those funds go to the lower earner
regardless of parenting time and this is
the biggest sticking point because the
precedent that was set by silva v silva
and what we're addressing is the
incremental financial impacts of this
but it doesn't change the amount of
funds available it's actually going to
make clear guidelines so this litigious
nature every time anyone goes into a
family court it's the wild west you
never know what's going to happen
1647 would establish clear guidelines
for how those funds are are allocated it
would reduce our costs we are the most
litigious in the parenting organization
just to read from what they say just so
you can hear it because it's it's it's
well said
new hampshire is one of only nine states
lacking a presumptive parenting time
adjustment formula meaning based on how
much parenting time the children spend
with each parent instead it relies on
unnecessarily costly lengthy court
deviation procedures generally
inaccessible to lower income parents
meaning people don't have enough funds
to even fight this on both sides the
higher and the lower the lack of a
presumptive parenting time allocation an
integral component of mandated
presumptive child support arguably
violates federal regulatory requirements
and um
uh
basically saying this is the most
litigious nature of the law
and what this 1647 would do is just
simply say when some based on the
parenting time that's what you're paying
there will be i think some testimony
today about people talking about well
parenting time
allocating you know attaching funds the
amount of parenting time will create
the ability for
abusers to abuse their victims to hold
them somehow hostage
the parenting time is established it's
called a parenting petition i deal with
this every day the parenting decision is
is is agreed upon separately and in
advance of any kind of child funds as
they're allocated by the judge because
the uniform support order is what's
called the uso is what the the judge
hands you when you find out what you'll
be paying or receiving
so the parenting time is not in any way
that
associated with or based on the amount
of time you have the that you have the
children so when another you know group
may get up today and say well this will
allow abusers to abuse their children it
is not in my case i have them more than
55 of the time but i'm left with
zero amount of funds that would have
been allocated on this per our child
support guidelines because of silva v
silva and we also in advance of that
we're already that one of the highest
paying states in the in the country 2014
we got a c by the parenting organization
in 2019 we got an f because we're the
third highest as in failure and this is
the nature of what we're discussing the
impact of the court the finance but the
details of what
relates to the finance committee
court costs would go down people's
parenting time would be
would be
clear the funds would be clear there
wouldn't be as much litigious nature and
also the the child support reserve is is
a little tricky one but that basically
means that someone's going to pay 50 a
month regardless of what they're earning
but again that has to be the higher
earner
there's another bill out there right now
that talks between 50 and 60. you know
that's only 10 percent that the other
bill would apply to because you have to
be the higher earner you have to be the
51 percent of the income to be the
higher earner so between 50 and 60 is
the only area you get it
it replicates all the other states it
does what is successful it is clear the
interest of acting up that our courts
are somehow going to be impacted or this
abusers you know kind of
holding their their the victims hostage
is just i don't know why anyone would
say that because everyone knows it's
agreed to by every parenting
organization the cars he studied the
dartmouth study this national npo is
that children do best when they're with
both parents that's been made clear why
would there be any other interest in
expressing otherwise so so a question
for representative weber
it's really a question of you because
i'm a visitor here and a a ringer today
i'm i'm very uncomfortable because it
seems like what we're having is a whole
nother hearing on the policy underlying
this bill which has already been decided
by the
children and family law committee and i
say that is somebody who has actually
practiced law in this area back in the
late stone age in vermont
when we did in fact allocate between the
two parents based not only on the
differential between incomes but the
differential between time
spent and it wasn't who had control it
was the time spent
i
have opinions about this bill but i
think i ought to defer to the policy
committee on the policy of the bill
because they heard everybody speak not
just one set of people
and i truly think we ought to confine
ourselves here
solely to the question of
i i think is this going to change court
costs in any way is very valid for this
committee i also think
the question of whether this is going to
have any impact whatsoever
on state
obligations for payment for kids
whose needs are not being met
under whatever the scheme is that we
come up because that's that those are
state funds
but i'm very uncomfortable with this
whole re-examination of the policy
behind
the um
behind something which has been
considered by the children and family
law committee
and and where decisions have been made
already
uh and i i i
i'm a visitor here so i don't know the
reasons for this but
it it seems peculiar to me so i just
wanted to raise that as a concern thank
you
you're you're welcome and if you get to
the point where you're just really
uncomfortable to a point where you can't
bear it any longer
you can excuse yourself
um but the reason i'm never going to get
please don't interrupt
i didn't interrupt you
um
the reason we're listening to this is
twofold
one the sponsor of the bill asked us to
to hear from ms toll and i invited mr
denham
up
okay i
when when i'm casting a vote
relative to
money
i want to understand the mechanics of
what's going on underneath it so that
when we do talk about the money piece i
know whether or not it makes sense given
what i understand about the underlying
policy so
i i have no issue with us getting
smarter before we vote i think
intelligent voting is better
than not having the information so
at this point i've tried to be courteous
to ms toll and mr denham to let them say
what they wanted to say because it was
all educational
but i i asked two questions earlier does
this reduce the amount of money for the
kid and i think i heard no it doesn't it
just shifts the percentages and two
because
we're proposing a formula in this
bill
it should make it much more easier for
the family courts to assess
who pays how much in a joint custody
situation
and to me
the logic of that suggests
that
the state costs could be reduced because
there's going to be less
fighting over an arbitrary amount of
money being uh selected and so
so knowing what i know from the
testimony i'm i'm now kind of confident
that i disagree with the fiscal note
because the fiscal note said that it's
going to result in additional litigation
and because we've been made smarter i
don't think that's true
so um
so thank you for your comment um
but uh
i i i just think it's in everyone's
interests to include the public that
when we make a decision about money
we're not doing it in isolation so that
that's where i'm coming from uh uh
representative wyler
thank you mr chairman
mr dinan since you've revealed that you
have 55 parenting
how is the money split and what will
this bill change currently all the funds
that were allocated so in to use
somewhat hypothetical numbers
we were assigned uh about 26 of both for
income because 22 for one child 26 of
our income when you have two children so
it's 26 percent of my income before
taxes it would be 26 percent of my uh
my i don't want to call her ex but my
children's mother um
would be paying 26 as well those are
combined and they should have been split
currently all those
100 of those funds go to her the lower
earner what this would do is based on
parenting time it would give me a credit
is the term that the the law uses 1647
uses and brendan uses but basically
would say they're with me 50 of the time
so thus 50 of that those funds should be
with me currently i can't pay for camps
i can't pay for clothing there's another
law called co-dare if one parent has all
the funds the other parent i can't make
that person do anything you know there's
no way it means of me telling them how
to spend their money so currently if the
children don't have clothing or they
can't go to a camp i have no input on
that that's where this becomes a real
problem it's one parent
get makes all the parenting decisions
that will come down to how they're given
driver's licenses how they get car
insurance how they get a cellular
telephone television school books so all
those funds to answer your question i
apologize for carrying on would be split
between two households and it wouldn't
be based on 55 it would still be 50 50.
because now you're giving all you're
giving all the money to the other one
parent the lord
the low earner doesn't matter if that
person makes a dollar less than the high
owner
all the funds per soba be silva go and
this is where i don't think a lot of
people understand how it really works
and the family in law did speak on this
as well that the family law committee
children family law committee especially
kim rice in the legislature it was her
the testament was her own it did pass
and there is another bill that's out
there called sb 431 i don't want to
confuse our discussions it's a senate
bill that suffered the same scrutiny
what this law would do
is simply provide
the
the people that may speak against the
spills it actually provides real bumpers
it provides a real road that everyone
can drive down and get to the same
destination with clear prescribed
numbers
the current silva v silva and the other
opposing bill turns everything to the
wild west it would say that
they would not give any relief to the to
the higher earner so currently i have no
input on how any of the funds are spent
this is the same with all
parents and believe me there's moms that
are the higher earners and the the lower
earning
dads
they don't really their their effort is
to stay underemployed it really creates
a scenario where
if you're the lower earner you have to
protect your
making less than 50
of the total and you'll do a lot of
things to do that and i'm not going to
go into details of my personal situation
but it promotes less funds being
available for both children that's what
the current law would do that's what sb
431 would do
14 16 16 excuse me 1647 is the what
every other state uses it's called the
offset method we're actually in
violation of federal law currently
that's what's being told and i think the
discussions on you know
this is a financial discussion i'm just
giving you more education a little bit
of details but what's being talked about
is that the the actual
things that i mentioned the parenting
time being associated with somehow
abusers
that's a again it's done before the
parenting position petition where we
have 50 50 and this is want to be clear
about my answer it wouldn't change based
on a day-to-day i had i have four hours
more this week so that's gives me
another percent it's 50 50. it's in our
parenting petition it's a parenting plan
signed off by all parties the judge both
parents and that's established then
after that the uniform support order the
uso is established so there's no there's
no way that the two can can overlap or
intercede and this is what needs to be
understood
the court's right let's say we
understand that all right all right uh
representative do you have a follow-up
no thank you thank you for increasing my
understanding it doesn't seem fair the
way it is presently thank you it's not
just unfair it it's
our children are suffering because of it
i have no input on how any of the funds
are spent and this is what's interesting
about any party that speaks against this
law what is their interest in saying
that that both parents
shouldn't have say on how the funds are
spent for the best interests of their
children how could that be and it that
would go against what every
the dartmouth school the carthy school
the npo why would anyone say this well
i'm finding out because i don't like
conspiracy theories but a lot of the
groups that are speaking against this
bill are actually funded by our
association please let's just wait to
hear from them without you impugning
anything all right
so representative walner
i i was wondering it is the question of
you mr chair whether or not there's
someone from the department that's going
to speak on this i i'm
interested to see what the financial
aspect of this is and how it affects the
state
that's a good question i was going to
ask when they're through if there's
anyone else that would like to testify
so
do you miss towns you have
i did want to answer a question that you
had asked pat abrami
representative abrami and that was
because of the judicial note saying that
this would cause
court costs to rise
so i wanted to address that because
what that isn't referring to
is that since 2019
all of the court orders that have been
issued for child support for shared
parenting have been done under the
umbrella of silva v silva so we have
thousands of families out there who have
had poor child support orders issued
where one household is hamstrung
compared to the other and if this law is
addressed it will probably need some um
there'll be a wave of parents coming in
looking for to be addressed
okay just to make sure i'm hearing you
that there's probably a two or three
year backlog of these joint custody
orders that are going to have to be
resolved
using this formula and therefore in the
short term there could be a higher
judicial expense but the expectation is
once we hit stable state we're probably
going to have a lower number uh going
forward is it is that fair that's very
fair i just didn't want to leave that
open because there is some truth to the
fact that there are folks out there who
are going to want to have their
i really truly appreciate your
clarification that was very helpful
representative
weber
that was exactly the question i had so
she has answered it thank you
i think it's it's being designed in that
the use of mark oh yes sir and the
reason we do that is because it's being
broadcast and recorded so we want to
make sure we hear you we're on tv right
now uh yes
um
it's done nothing for my celebrity so
don't don't get too nervous
i don't want to delete your celebrity
yes um so the
the
time that every three years uh these
child support orders uh the parenting
petition is reevaluated automatically
every three years what i think 1647
would do is be wrapped into that that
rotation so when someone's up for the
next three years it actually would help
reduce those costs even further because
that's going to happen anyway people
already get their hearing it should be
every three years
okay i do have an in the weeds question
uh it does
there's a lot of good reasons to pass
this lots of good reasons i just want to
know if
mechanically
we've we're going to insert a perverse
incentive
for one parent or another to increase
their fixed costs in the amount that
they pay for mortgages
and the on the other hand sometimes they
can't help it their rents got raised and
so so how does that changing of the
fixed cost
get factored in over time so the child
support calculation is a percentage of
overall income and so our rsas on child
support allow deviation from the
standard calculation if there are
extraordinary expenses like let's say
the children are going to private school
and there's a funding that needs to be
funded by both parents so there's
there's other ways that judges can
modify
outside of income and parenting time to
right the ship but overall a standard
child support calculation starts with
income
and then child care expenses life and
sorry health insurance those are the
really the key factors that are at the
standard for calculating child support
and then as i said our child support
laws allow for extraneous things to be
evaluated by a judge and balance out the
books okay earlier i could have sworn i
heard you mentioned mortgages as one of
the major components of the fixed cost
calculation did i mishear you that was
in relationship to silva v silva so when
the judgment was made interpreting our
current rsas the way that they're
drafted
they
use the term fixed costs and so it
narrowed the ability of anybody to be
able to get an adjustment for parenting
time based on that
uh thank you for that clarification are
there other questions for these panel
members uh representative irv just one
question so i get the
situation with the
incomes roughly equal or even you know
close to equal that makes a lot of sense
to me i understand why that wants to be
changed
what will be the impact on the situation
with just the other extreme very low
earner very high earner
so you'll you'll see um again the total
child support order um very similar to
is what you would see today but they're
going to increase it by 50
recognizing that the households have
twice the costs
and then the higher earners percentage
of child support dollars will go
to the other parent
for to make up the income difference um
in order to compensate for two very
diverse economic households the child
support credit uh will be given on
parenting time but it will be at that
lesser dollar amount
and the calculation um
allows for that equalizing of of the
households so that both households have
the same
standard of living if you will
okay any other questions for these two
[Music]
thank you so much for coming um
is there anyone
in attendance that would like to
participate um
i i don't know your name but you're
welcome to come up and introduce
yourself in the microphone and tell us
the organization you represent
i appointed you
oh you're pointing to me oh yeah yeah
thank you yeah
and i also have a handout if i can just
pin that out and then i will get started
good morning mr chairman my name is
richard head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch and
i'm going to switch seats because i'm
getting blocked here
1d or 2ds
uh 1d
as opposed to the former representative
who couldn't spell his name and put two
d's in his name
there are a couple things i just wanted
to point out on behalf of the judicial
branch one with regard to the policy of
using parenting time relative to
calculating child support we have no
position on that that is not
an issue that that i'm here to address
i did want to talk about our uh fiscal
note and the timing of what our fiscal
note was prepared which was on the
original bill and what is printed in
here is based on the the original bill
not on the amended bill we have not been
asked for an updated fiscal note
so this is based on on the original
one thing to also know is that the
original bill did not have
section seven which is in the current
bill
and and that section seven was added at
our request during the hearing in
children and family law
okay pause so that those who don't speak
in section numbers yep i can uh page 4
line 25
which is an applicability clause
okay i see it now just give a second to
look at it
okay thank you what were you going to
say then so the applicability clause
refers to what you heard about in the
prior testimony which is on a three-year
cycle
child support orders are reviewed on a
as a matter of routine
in the original bill
that natural three-year cycle did not
apply and it would have upon enactment
applied to all
orders
those that had been previously issued
and going forward all on the same day
all at the same time would have created
in our mind a rush to the courthouse
and that would have created substantial
burden on the courts at that moment of
effective date that has been addressed
by the children of family law
through this paragraph uh in section 7
on page 4 line 25 so we appreciate that
that was at our request and they and
they did do that
so finish the thought what how would
that uh modify your fiscal note it would
modify it in the sense that it would
reduce the
single point
of load and spread it out over time and
that obviously reduces the
impact on a particular day it doesn't
mean that there won't be the same number
of orders that need to be modified it
just it smooths it out in a way that is
beneficial to the court staff court
judicial resources
be able to manage that load over time as
opposed to on a on a point day
so do you think that's a substantive
enough modification that we should uh
ask for an updated fiscal note so that
if this goes to the senate they've
they've got the best and latest version
i do and also for the second point that
i want to address which is the handout i
think would also be useful if it was
incorporated into the into the
judicial branch's fiscal note i will say
all of that is going to lead to a
conclusion that it's indeterminable
because we can't predict today
exactly what that load is going to be
but there are elements
in the way that the amendment was
drafted
and
the beneficial
aspects of this new section 7 that would
be reflected in our fiscal note
uh in in anticipation of the question
would you be able to guess at um a good
guess at the quantity of
cases that might be in the backlog that
would need to be reviewed are we talking
about just an order of magnitude are we
talking a thousand five thousand i have
no clue what the quantity is a fair
question
as to the precision no but generally
what i can tell you is that in if we're
talking domestic matters generally we're
talking about 6 000 filings a year
breaking that down into cases that have
child support orders
parenting plans becomes much more
complicated and i don't have a reduction
to that level of specificity but when
we're talking domestic orders we're in
the magnitude of 6 000 per year of new
cases
and then so those cases that have
parenting plans and in child support
orders
would be under the new system and then
those that have been previously issued
would get filtered through on a
three-year cycle
so that's a beneficial aspect of it in
the handout
one of the things that this amendment
does that was not in the original bill
that we have to take into account from
the court's perspective in
how does it get implemented because we
are talking about a
uh a group of litigants that are
primarily unrepresented by legal counsel
so the simpler the better from the
court's perspective because
as it becomes more complicated they're
more questions to clerk staff and this
is really a clerk staff issue
not a judge issue so much but clerks are
are are really the front line of
confused litigants
who are approaching
so let's put a pin in that is it your
position that this is sufficiently
simple enough or do you think this is
overly complex still this is a very
complex bill um as as amended because
and i'll walk you through why i think
that and you may disagree with me but i
want to give you the specific reasons so
the preview of coming attractions though
um
you're going to make the case that this
is more complex
do you have an alternative that to
propose that would be simpler
i do not have language fair fair point i
do not have specific language it and and
in part let me give you a little more
background
this amendment was proposed in the
committee hearing so the hearing before
children and family law was not so much
about this amendment
as it was about the original bill which
didn't have sort of these complexities
and we didn't have the issues i think it
and then coming here today
my focus was less on sort of the policy
and what i was assuming at the end of
the day is you're probably going to tell
me
deal with it in the senate in the in the
policy committee um but if not i'm happy
to deal with it in the in this committee
i hadn't intended to do that um but i i
i think we're sort of getting into a
little bit of a blind alley on this if
your position is this is too complex but
you don't have an alternative today
it may be that you have to share that
alternative with the senate so that they
have something to compare and contrast
and it's a fair point um and i do think
it is
you know some of the original language
it just had some simpler aspects to it
and i also think by the way that the
senate bill that's crossing over
does itself have some it tries to do
some of these things and that bill
actually does
have a somewhat simpler approach than
this bill does
so it may just be at the end of the day
trying to figure out how these two bills
which are sort of crossing over each
other
can sort of get merged and i think
that's the context in which
the language will ultimately get worked
out is trying to figure out what's good
from from the senate bill what's good
from the house bill and trying to to
bring that to a consensus all right i i
understand that point what else would
you like to tell us so with regard to
just very briefly i did want to identify
where it is
that
we as as a court system and our clerks
are going to have a great deal of
difficulty in terms of just processing
these these
the litigants coming in to try to figure
this out like how does that apply to
them and i can be very brief about this
i i think the handout lays it out
but in the handout what what the handout
is is is essentially extracting out all
the new definitions that are contained
in the bill
and and tries to put it into a single
page because it's a they're all word
formulas
so they say this minus this is this
definition
and and one of the key ones is the new
paragraph which would be roman numeral
12 xii which is the definition of child
support obligation calculation
and that then feeds into really a number
of things one is it tells you who is the
obligor and who is the obligee simple
enough i have no issue with that
once you get into definitions that
require
a review of other definitions to figure
out what the count how to make the
calculation you're adding to complexity
in a pro se litigant's sort of capacity
to do these calculations and it's like
looking at a tax form you can say well
you convert it into a form all they have
to do is check it through
tax forms are essentially trying to
convert the tax code to a form and it
becomes very
complicated so if i look and i'll focus
on on roman
12 which says a parent's household
responsibility
minus the parent's financial
is the definition of child support
obligation calculation
and parental support is also defined as
what is the obligates child support
obligation calculation this is like the
essential calculation
within that the first part of it the
parent's household responsibility is
defined
in the new paragraph 13
and that is
defined to say essentially the parent's
household responsibility percentage
which is another defined term
times the total support obligation which
is yet another defined term
so if we go
continuing sort of on this course of
trying to figure out what these mean in
paragraph 11 13 the parents household
responsibilities percentage is defined
by the new paragraph 14 none of these
were in the original bill
and that
creates the first real substantive and
strong stumbling block because it
defines household responsibility
percentage
as the percentage of household
responsibility designated in the
parenting plan where now by doing that
incorporating a different statute 461 a
which has no
term household responsibility and the
parenting plan as currently designed
does not come up with a percentage
figure so the parenting plan we have a
template based upon the statute 461a
what is required and this number just
doesn't exist in that parenting plan so
the courts are going to have to figure
out what that is
create a percentage that would come out
of this
out of this
statute out of this new bill
and and we got to figure out is that the
same thing as residential responsibility
which is defined or is it something new
when we're talking household
responsibility because we're using
different words so i'm assuming it means
something different but truthfully i'm
not quite sure what it is we're going to
have to figure that out because it's
ambiguous that's where we sort of get
into this issue of how do we define
stuff in the court system we look at web
series we look at sort of the common and
ordinary meaning of stuff
that may have sort of kicked us in the
road of where we are today in terms of
trying to
put this together
i'm not going to go through each of
these but
these definitions all rely on other
definitions
that
feed upon themselves and every time you
do that you add a little bit of
ambiguity
and then from the court's perspective
if you've ever tried to
follow
a definition by by having to read three
other definitions and plug it in it
becomes very complicated for a lay
person
and then our clerks have to help people
figure it out and it becomes
a burden on the courts as these become
more complicated my only message and i
do think it's something that is is
better addressed in
probably in the in the policy committee
mostly in part because of time here in
getting the parties who are who are
interested in this together but i do
think it's going to be sort of a a
figuring out of what works in the senate
bill what works and how spill
and and putting them together and i
think it's going to
be a process
are you able to pause there yeah uh
representative walner i'm i'm curious on
on your opinion on this
um
given given that we're looking at the
worksheet that's been advanced and and
we understand now that it this worksheet
uh flows from the language of the bill
let's let's just assume for the purpose
of this question
that
this
worksheet is more complex than it needs
to be
that the senate bill is likely to have
an alternative
is do you think
our
opinion
our division iii our opinion
is is is relevant to whether or not we
like this worksheet and what we do with
this bill based on whether or not we
like this worksheet
i'm just curious what your thoughts are
i still reserve the right to disagree
but i'm curious what you're thinking
well what i'm thinking is it seems like
this needs more time
than this division's got i mean i think
we have to report this
out by wednesday
is that right
and i feel like it's really
a pretty complex
issue here and we still have not heard
from the department which is what is
what i would like to hear is i want to
hear what this financially is going to
cost the state
because it feels like to me at least
there are financial
issues here
some for the court certainly
but also in the area of tanf and some of
the
some of the
programs that we are
most concerned about in this division
all right that that's that's good thank
you um
so i'm i'm going to consider this uh
handout this attachment as being
pertinent to our decision and i'm going
to assume that simple is better because
of all the
court time that could be taken by a more
complex form if it's too complex
so so that that gives me pause there
um
before i invite the department of health
and human services up i i don't want to
uh have you run out of time is there
anything else you you still want to tell
us you know i don't feel i'm not going
to go through the entire
handout i just gave has similar issues
throughout but i will be here as through
the rest of the hearing if other
questions come up i'm happy to
participate thank you mr head thank you
is there somebody from the department
here to speak
yeah oh wait a second did you have a
question for mr head i'm
it's um more of sort of an observation
but i'll put it in the form of a
question
because i genuinely don't know the
answer to this but
mr head
in my experience in vermont a very long
time ago
when
this allocation was made so you're
adjusting not only based on
the amount that each parent earns but
the amount of time each child spends
with each parent
my question is
is there somewhere in the statute
a definition of what's going to be
counted
in terms of how much time
because
in vermont what happened back
sometime in the late stone age
was that
the litigation turned on
gee is it fair to count only where the
kid sleeps or is it
more important to look at the quality of
the time spent with each parent and
who's actually spending the money as
opposed to providing a bed at night
and might those questions
lead to more court time being needed
as we go through the rolling
calculations because
each
family's
actual
situation is different from most other
families and and might that be a source
of more court time
more court clerk time more judge time
rather than less so thank you for the
question and it does refresh my memory
because it's it's an uh a point i made
meant to make before when i was talking
about section seven
one of the things i think this this has
maybe competing more and less court time
issues which is one i do think
in part of the reason that the fiscal
note reflects what it does and would
remain the same
is
in part you shift litigation
from
child support calculations to parenting
time so so essentially you're shifting
the the
litigation from this statute which is
458c
to the statute dealing with parenting
time which is 461a
and and
um
and so essentially
where we where we have parties who are
not reaching agreement throughout where
we have those in which
there is a litigious
couple
and and therefore requiring the court to
be making decisions as opposed to
reaching agreement
the focus it's anticipated
and and and obviously time will tell it
is anticipated that
there will be a shift in litigation
focus from
child support
to the parenting plan and to the
parenting time
that's true of any of these bills but
once child support is more closely tied
to parenting time
that's where the litigation is going to
occur because it has
a direct
impact on child support and the
financial side of it so
whether or not it's a wash or not or
whether or not there's more litigation i
don't know
but it would definitely be not
definitely i'm sorry
we assume there will be a shift in the
litigation towards the parenting plan
and and so really having that as was
said before that's determined earlier in
the process and in the litigation would
occur in in that in that context
do you have a follow-up
okay that was that was good thank you um
all right so
so in my mind's eye
what would be the perfect test of
simplicity mr head i'm i'm sorry i had
this was for you
um
in in in in
the the the best test for simplicity
would be
if we took a
a couple that's in dispute over the
amount of child support they each have
to pay to the other
it would be great if this form this
worksheet was so simple that the law was
so simple that you could take
two high school graduates
you know have them each independently
when they know enough of the court's
decision could sit down and fill this
out and share it with each other and
then they'd basically be the same number
is is that objective for simplicity
achievable in this environment or is is
that just wishing for something we we're
not going to get to anyways it's
probably not 100 achievable but it is
the aspirational goal
and and and if you were to sleep on this
for a week or two do you think you'd be
able to come up with a vision of that
aspiration
with input from others
all right
that's good information thank you mr
head and then and then uh the department
and then as always your your full name
and the department you represent please
thank you representative edwards and
members of the committee
my name is lisa dekatowski and i will
spell my last name for the record it's d
e k
u t
s
i am the bureau chief with the bureau of
child support services
here on behalf of the department of
health and human services
still good morning
i'm susan brisson i'm the chief staff
attorney for the department of health
and human services and briston is
b-r-i-s-s-o-n
you for the opportunity uh to give us
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on house bill 1647.
the department of health and human
services through the bureau of child
support services administers the child
support program
consistent with the social security act
title roman
roman numeral 4d
and
the bureau has an interest in making
sure that the legislature is up to date
on the current status of our quadrennial
review the guidelines review that we are
statutorily required to complete
um at least once every four years we are
currently in a review year and our
quadrennial review is well underway
we anticipate to have a
updated
report
by the end of this calendar year
which we anticipate will certainly yield
some helpful recommendations for the
legislature
moving forward as the considerations of
these bills relative to the child
support guidelines calculations come
forward
so certainly
want the legislature to be aware of that
additionally
as
mentioned
from prior testimony
in terms of the fiscal impacts of this
bill that the department potentially
foresees
certainly in the event that the
self-support reserve
is increased that threshold is what we
use for the standard of minimal support
orders
so there is the potential and certainly
an indeterminable amount
that we may see an increase in such
minimum orders which could we could
assume may have a corresponding increase
in families and children requiring
either additional or new public
assistance
from the state
or its other
financial assistance programs
and
certainly we
in the event that the bill is passed we
might even see some indeterminable
costs to
if the child support guidelines are
changed there may be some costs
associated with changing our child
support guidelines worksheets and our
online calculator things from a
technology standpoint that we would have
to
um
address and adopt so
so let me let me
pause you for a second
um
i'm just curious about this new
population
that would go from the current uh
reserve number to the perspective
reserve number from 14 something to 15
something
um if if
if they were just to go from the minimum
to the next minimum
um
how how much more would each of those
instances cost the state i know that
overall this is an indeterminable
problem but i'm just wondering if you
just take it down to the micro analysis
of one case if we've got a number to
throw at it so we have a point of
reference
well what i could say
um i can't speak to what the potential
costs would be certainly that would be
in unknown for us
but what i can say that currently in our
within the bureau of child support
services the orders
and the families in which we serve which
we serve both
we're a third party neutral
program we serve both parties
persons who are responsible to pay and
those who are responsible to receive
the current
minimum orders for support in our
current caseload is roughly about an
eight percent
so
i i have to play this back to make sure
i'm hearing you uh so currently
eight percent of the total population
that's uh that would be affected by this
law eight percent are now
bouncing up against the the
the maximum reserve level
that they're within the maximum reserve
level now eight percent is that what
that eight percent number reflects i'm
sorry let me clarify the um
the bureau of child support services um
collects and enforce orders that we um
are enforcing currently eight percent of
our caseload of orders that we
uh collect and enforce on
that doesn't include orders that are
represented outside of
our
authority
our current caseload consists of about
eight percent of those cases
all right i'll just admit i don't
understand but uh as long as the rest of
committee does i'm i'm willing to move
on i think i can clarify uh the first
thing to know is that not every child
support order is
enforceable through the department
so there are plenty of people who have
child support so we don't have any
obviously any data about orders that we
don't enforce
in our case load which
over thirty thousand cases
eight percent of them are currently at
the fifty dollar a month minimum
so that means that
in those cases the
the parties with the children as opposed
to the party who's paying child support
would would be more at risk at needing
public assistance because of the low
amount of child support
so that eight percent would maybe move
to nine percent or
or some incremental
change it could um the other thing to
remember is that the the eight percent
number right now does include um
the obligors that we have that are in
prison
and most of them have a minimum child
support order of 50.50 a month so
they're into slightly
different category slightly different
category
but okay so now i think i'm i'm still
wanting to know an answer to a question
you may not be prepared for and that is
let's say it goes from eight percent to
nine percent that incremental one
percentage point how much would a case
or that whole one percent how much more
would that add to the state spending
i'm not sure it's possible to know that
because it's
dependent the the number with that deals
with the self-support reserve is all
based on the obligors income
um we would need to know what the
obligees income is
um as well to be able to to be able to
figure out if
then uh the family of the obligee would
then be um
in the need of for for public assistance
um i can point out that the under the
current child support formula the one
that we're living under right now
that
for one child a an obligor who makes
fifteen thousand dollars a year or less
is supposed to pay
twenty five point six percent of this of
child support
for their child
generally we run into the self-support
reserve with that because that's a
fairly large one a fairly large number
of the percentage but as you
incrementally increase the obligor's
income
you creep you creep away from the
self-support reserve and then the minute
the the obligor is making more than the
self-support reserve
then the percentages
in the child support formula uh come
into play
okay
just just as a finance guide let you
know my head's starting to hurt because
i just want a number um but you can't
give me one i understand
do you have other information you want
to share with us
no that's it representative edwards
unless there's questions that we could
answer representative walner has a
question
so
when i'm thinking about this i'm
thinking about
the lower income
side of the the
family member that had the lower the
lower income
don't doesn't this have the potential
to push a lot of those folks
into
needing state support through the tanf
program or food stamps
because
they will now not or
child care reimbursement being on the
child care subsidy
and that's another one of the areas that
income eligibility is what determines
whether they how much child how much
child care they are entitled to
so doesn't this have a potential in all
of those areas
of causing the state to incur more cost
thank you for the question i again i
think the department's stance is that
certainly by you know that the costs are
indeterminable and naturally if you're
increasing the self-support reserve
which is increasing the amount of
minimal support orders there may be
the potential for the impact on families
needing additional supports whether
that's through
additional programs that the state can
provide certainly i am not able to speak
to the income eligibility requirements
of the tanf programs or the child care
programs that you spoke of but certainly
the
the bureau of child support services
would take the position that there may
be a potential impact of families
needing more assistance yes
has the department
done any analysis with
the tanf
department or the child care department
or the food stamp has there been any
analysis of how this might affect the
caseload
and the
amount of funding it would need to
make this work
as a member
as a bureau of the member of the
division of economic and housing
stability which consists of the multiple
programs that you've spoken to it's
certainly something we haven't taken a
proactive approach to evaluate and
assess the analysis
as a as you had referenced here we are
the bureau of child support services is
looking towards the new quadrennial
review that will be conducted this year
to provide us with the information that
we need
that will thus be
presented to all of you
to assist in looking at a current
economic analysis and the cost of living
of children
today with more current and updated
information that may be
able to assist um in creating a you know
ultimately a fair and appropriate child
support guidelines
thank you no that's okay
okay so
after listening to this is it is it
close
enough for government work for me to
think of this bill into two two big
things
one we're changing the reserve numbers
for that are important to the
calculation but the second thing which
is almost totally separable is we're
trying to create a formula a simple
formula in order to calculate
in these joint custody situations how
much
is it fair to think of these in in two
big chunks
yes
okay all right um
are there any other questions uh
representative weber
i think i have one more because i'm
trying to play out how the calculations
work
and what the net effect might be
but in addition to the concern expressed
by representative walner about the
people at the very low end of the scale
will this not have
an effect that might be significant for
tana or other
pro state programs
when we have
an obligor who has a relatively high
income
and the kids are with a relatively
lower income parent
who might
buy the reduction in the amount that
they're getting from the obligor be
forced into needing
extra supports whether they be child
care or housing subsidies or other
things
is is that a
potential
issue that we ought to keep in the back
of our minds
it's certainly um yes whenever we are
considering
um again
you know the goal of the child support
guidelines and the goal is to um try to
provide the most
a fair amount of support and enough
support
to support the families so all of those
things should be taken into
consideration
follow up
no okay
so i'm i'm trying to uh focus now just
on the first component which is which is
the
reserve amount
if we wanted
because it's simple and we only want to
deal with one variable if we wanted to
freeze
the 14 812 and keep it at that
and not go to 15 456
we can't really do that by changing this
bill in a simple way that we'd have to
go back to this
2021 fpl or something to make an
adjustment in that
so the um
the federal poverty level is set by the
federal department of health and human
services
um and that is um set uh every april 1st
so a new
self-support reserve amount would be set
for 2022
this
coming april
in terms of
whether to increase as you
recommend or suggest
you know i really don't know that the
department
really can speak to one or the other
certainly
but would be willing to
assist
with anybody in the development of you
know language or insight
for future if need be all right to be
clear i wasn't suggesting it i was
floating the question as a brainstorming
opportunity to help me understand the
connection between all of these
different laws this is a new area i've
we
normally don't get into this area
uh it sounds to me though after hearing
you what you may have just educated me
on
is that this change from 14 8 to 15 4
is is basically on
autopilot because we're just following
the federal law and we're updating it
this this this change in reserve is not
based on this law it's just another
factor that's going on on in parallel
correct our the self-support reserve is
is defined in the statute currently as
115 of the federal self-support reserve
the original version of the bill upped
it to 120 and then the amendment upped
it to 150. obviously the number
would be the number yeah okay so so what
we do have in our control with this
particular bill is whether we accept the
115 or the 150 or some other number
correct all right i think i understand
okay do you are there any other
questions
do you have anything that you think we
need to know that we didn't ask
that's a question thank you for the
opportunity for that question um no
thank you representative edwards uh
you're welcome thank you for coming by
uh
i i think we know more i don't know that
i know what we should do but is there
anyone else in attendance that would
like to speak
come come forward state your name and
tell us if you represent yourself or an
organization please
hi i'm kevin watten i'm just a parent of
three girls representing myself
w o
t t o n
so i just wanted to uh address a few
things
uh the first being when we were talking
about how the clerks were gonna have to
have more paperwork
um i've represented myself in family
court for the last six years might be
five
you currently if you go ask a clerk to
help you fill out paperwork they tell
you they are not your legal
representation
they have no legal right to do that
so realistically whether you change the
formula or not they're not doing more
paperwork
that's just my experience in the court
so i don't see that adding
any expense to the court or any
confusion there when the clerks can just
say we have no legal right to help you
on this paperwork
ah secondly i just like to give
another little piece
of knowledge to you guys about some of
this stuff
so
currently with child support in new
hampshire
the uh when it was set up it was set up
so long ago
that women weren't working and that's
just a fact it was before i was born
so the federal government
ordered the states to set it all up and
the federal government then set up tanf
and when the states ordered child
support
because the women weren't working 72
cents for every dollar in child support
ordered is reimbursed to tanf
that is still a fact today
so when they sit there and they say 8
percent
are the lower incomes
that means guys like me and my family
who i currently will be paying about
four hundred thousand dollars in child
support
tanf is receiving from the federal
government
about three hundred thousand dollars so
for every dollar the state gets from or
has ordered me to pay
they get about 72 cents
that adds up if you have only eight
percent on the low income
there's a lot of profit there for the
state
and i just want to point that out
because i find it very frustrating
when people sit there and say oh
and i know it's not all of you guys
but when my kids and my child support
are being used to balance the state
budget for tanf
and my family doesn't benefit from that
and i do know that there are kids that
need it but when it becomes a political
thing that's used against me in the
family courts
and the current laws i find it very
frustrating very unfair
and personally just unconstitutional
have you said everything you wanted to
say that's it i i i have a question for
you if you'll entertain one yep
when when you
i i i just want to uh make sure i
understand what you're saying when you
say that um
the money goes through tanf and and at
72 cents per dollar of what you pay
um and you said that that's a profit
that is a kick back to the state of new
hampshire
okay profit kickback
i just want to understand it's it's my
belief that that money that goes back
stays within the tanf funding
and is used to support
tanf payments that it isn't
retained to
increase our state surplus
but it is used to increase the amount of
resources available for tanf payments
do you do
do you know which way
that works i did go meet with the
department at one point and they uh they
as far as i know it does stay in the
tanf department
they wouldn't give us a breakdown as to
where they spent that money
all right
a question by representative weiler
so
you pay money to the state
no the state
takes
my money directly out of my paycheck all
right so
money is taken from you by the state yes
it supposedly goes
to your ex-wife or whoever's taking care
of the children yes
you don't think she's getting
the whole amount that was taken from
your pay no she does get the whole
amount
she gets the whole amount and they i
think they charge like 25 bucks a year
for maintaining our account but what
they don't talk about in their
department is that for every dollar they
order
they get a 72 cents kickback from the
federal government
that's money that comes into new
hampshire's tanf
program
based on that so when they sit here and
they're worried about raising the self
reserve
ten dollars a week
they don't talk about how
guys like me who pay four hundred
thousand dollars in child support are
getting them a three hundred thousand
dollar kickback
are you saying four hundred thousand
dollars what what number are you using
the i have been ordered to pay four
hundred about four 400 thousand dollars
in child support over the course of my
oh totally you're talking about total
over the lifetime okay
i now understand that money i was going
to congratulate you on your career and
ask if you're not no that's not that's
not weekly no okay thank you
thank you for enlightening us
bill i just wanted to make you guys
aware of that because it doesn't get
talked about very often
i i appreciate it are there any other
questions i would just like to hear
the um
health and human service folks maybe
respond to that with
how that works with the federal with the
federal money
great minds think alike i was just gonna
if there are no other questions uh i'd
i'd thank you for your testimony and i'd
like hhs to come back and
and um
and restate what they think they heard
and and and how the money flows through
the child support system
when somebody is on tanf through the
state of new hampshire
they assign their right to child support
to the state
so if they have a child support order
uh
money coming in that money then is
collected by the by the state and is
kept by the state
uh to pay back the tanf that is going
to the household
in almost all cases
the money that's going into the
household is more than the child support
order that's coming in
in cases that are non-tanf
which is the vast majority of our cases
at this point
um money comes in money goes out there
is no there's no kickbacks there's no
the our system is funded
66 percent by the by the federal
government
so we submit to them a very detailed
list of expenses
and they
reimburse us 66 percent
when a in a tanf case when t when the
money is
paid back
if there are arrears
some of that money goes back to the
federal government because they've paid
for 66 percent of it so we give them 66
of it back
that is that's the there are some
incentive funds that we earn for
the certain number of uh getting enough
paternity
um cases done um
order establishment
establishing um
getting payments on towards arrears
but none of it is based on if we get a
higher child support number
uh in a particular case
which leaves us to to
be able to ask the court to establish
reasonable court orders because
because the numbers are based on what
what um
is happening in that individual
family so so to stick the finger on the
issue
uh is there a scenario where the
department collects from parents to
feed the system that then goes out the
other door
is there a scenario in which
the department um profits or retains a
surplus as a result of that
managing that transaction
no there isn't there's um in cases that
are that have never been on tanf the
the
obligee is charged 35
per year
for to uh
for all the costs
um but there are no other
no other expenses that are charged
okay so like in civil asset forfeiture
there's sometimes an argument that
there's a
policing for profit incentive to go do
that there's there's no sort of child
care for profit incentive going on in
your system
no sir and if and if in the very rare
case where the amount of child support
coming in
is close to the amount of the truck of
the of the tanf if the child support's
going to be more than the tanf
somebody the the person on tanf's going
to go off tanf and get the child support
the bigger amount
thank you are there questions
no i think that
cleared that up for me all right thank
you uh is there anyone else mr dejoy did
you have anything you wanted to share
with us
all right
uh i think uh what i'd like to do at
this point is before we take any further
action as a committee i would like to
recess until 12 30 which is just in six
seven minutes and this is just for uh
caucuses
because uh i wanna i wanna just check
with people to figure out
what we may want to do with this
we are now in recess until 12 30.
okay so it being 12 30 i'm going to call
us out of recess um
uh we just came back from
two uh partisan uh caucuses um
what what i i think uh we're predisposed
to doing is um
passing 1647 out of division three on an
otp
with a committee report that that says
that um
this this bill could use more work
specifically relative to trying to
simplify the the formulas and the
worksheets a little bit more so that
it's easier to access
for layman
um
um but that's just going to be part of
the committee recommendation i think
ultimately
we're going to we're looking like maybe
there's a committee a conference or
something that's going to happen to
fix this bill and that would be done by
the policy committee not us
so so that's that's that's what i where
i think we're at do you do you want to
share with us your thoughts before we do
a vote
well i don't i i don't really have
enough information
at this point
financial information i mean i'm on the
finance committee and i want to know
what does this call what is the
potential cost here to the state
how much will the case load increase i
mean
we will potentially have more
tanf
tan of payout will potentially have more
i'm fairly sure that
there will be more child care
costs by the state
food stamps housing i think and we
didn't get any of that information
today we got
we really
no one came to talk about those parts
the people from child support
pay are the collector basically
of the child support but we didn't hear
the other side of that
and what it means
to the state budget
and i thought that was what we were
supposed to do and
then it would be for me a value of
whether or not
the new
this new process
is worth
what it would would cost but i don't
have i couldn't
i couldn't defend it
our decision on a financial
reason
so so what's your preference for a
disposition on this bill today i would
put it i would put it to study
and spend some time over the next
several months
um figuring out
what it would cost
um really
maybe some sort it maybe we could do
something jointly with
the child and family law committee but
to me
this feels irresponsible of us to pass
this along when i i couldn't go out on
the street and say how much it's
what it means to the state
and that's who i'm supposed to be
looking at for right now if if i had an
otp vote to cast it would be because i
think there isn't uh a need for
this formula to help
satisfy the problem that we have
currently
that uh joint custody situations are
just on their face appear to be turning
out unfairly and that that in itself is
a big advance for new hampshire to have
that in place or is that not sufficient
in your mind
no because i i don't think i mean i
think that we need to obviously and
that's what's happening here is to look
at the formula and how
the child support is calculated and to
come up with what's a fair system
but we didn't do the other part of the
homework
and that was to figure out how much
other
state resources will need in order
to accomplish
the first i mean it feels like sort of a
we've only done half of the calculation
here and
um for me i need to i would want to know
what a policy like this
really means to state government
uh
thank you for that uh i'll just second
representative weiler i want to ask
mr ripple and and maybe the department
are are we asking for
numbers that are attainable with more
analysis or are we really
sort of stuck
in the indeterminable
world here
what's your opinion
i'm really not sure i think we would
depend on the department to provide that
information so they'd be better able to
answer than i am
anyone from the department want to
say that whether or not you think you
could actually produce us some analysis
so that we understand what the gov the
state costs are
thank you
again i still think we are in an
indeterminable state of in terms of a
cost analysis however i do hope that the
upcoming quadrennial review will assist
us in
you know finding some more
current
uh more
relative information that may
be beneficial in terms of cost analysis
follow-up
so what i hear from that is that
today you don't really have that
information you're working on it
and
my question would be when when will this
uh report be ready
um we are the quadrennial review report
is being conducted this year with the
anticipation of a final report uh
available by the end of december
and that that would probably provide us
with some of the information
that would make this
we would understand what exactly what
what it means to the state
yes it would give us more information on
the current child support guidelines
and how it
in comparison to the economic analysis
of the cost of raising children and how
we are currently applying those in a
case review with the courts and with the
department
so is there anyone that would be
available to work on on this
this quantitative analysis in parallel
with the quadrennial report instead of
in sync with it so that we could get
some information to the legislature in a
timely fashion
so the quadrennial review report will be
published and provided to the
legislature
following the analysis right you said
december
we need to decide sooner than that so my
question is is there a financial analyst
who can work on this in parallel instead
of waiting for the quadrennial so that
we have the analytical information we
would need to
help satisfy representative walner's
questions
well
sorry
i think from listening to the discussion
here um we would need to rely on um
some of our sister departments in in
tanf child care and and that that type
of thing so we'd have to reach out to
them to see
um
if they're if
who they have available and what what
the time looks like but
we could certainly do that
okay mr williams is it putting you on
the spot too much to ask you if you
think um
a financial analysis can be coordinated
within the department to to get us some
answers quicker rather than later
thank you president edwards thank you um
[Music]
john williams i'm the director of
legislative affairs and i think it's a
it's a good question and i know that
when we contract with the vendor as part
of our quad runner review and i'm glad i
have the subject matter experts with us
today we do sometimes build into that
analysis the use of that contractor in
the future prospectively not before the
report comes out but to assist with the
legislature and determining these cost
implications i would have to go back to
our agency to determine if we do have
the in-house available resources my
expectations are we gave due diligence
in the actual fiscal analysis that we
didn't provided to the lba on this and
at the end of the conversation at least
with our existing resources that's why
we came back
with an indeterminable impact as it
might relate to increased utilization or
families going on to the tan of
temporary aid for needy families so that
is a very long-winded answer that i
don't know the answer to the question
whether or not we can leverage any
additional resources such as a
contractor who actually does this kind
of financial economic analysis but
something something we could certainly
look into but i think in terms of your
timeline i don't see us being ready to
do that before your committee needs to
dispose of this bill
representative walner
i suggest we
retain this bill
for study and come back out with
something in
january okay so so play that out in in
in my head for me uh if if we division
three asked finance to retain it and
that recommendation was accepted then
what would happen to this bill what what
would then happen
[Music]
well i think that in the
what we should do
would be just to
study the bill for the you know
period from now to or
may or june until november
when we'd probably be asked to give some
sort of a report on whether this bill
should go for go forth in legislation in
january
i think it would give us the time we
need to get some
more accurate
numbers from the department
hear more
from there are other groups who work on
child support and that they are not here
today
and i would i think there's a lot more
information we need together before we
send this out
and maybe we do something jointly with
the child and family
law committee some sort of a study that
was joined i think that that would be
possible so that that's what i would do
but
okay i
i
i understand the intellectual argument i
i'm just itching to give the tools to
the judiciary to calculate a formula for
just uh joint custody if
i mean if we could just amend it so that
that's all that we passed i i i see
moving on that
representative what are your thoughts
sir
we really need data we won't have it
till the end of this
calendar year
this session will be over
it would take new bills
by people with more expertise than us
and they would have to take some time to
study what happened from the quadrennial
review
so there's nothing we can do with this
bill
practically right now
nobody's willing to move it on then
kill it in interim study
if that's what you want that's what's
going to happen to it so if you were to
make a motion what what would it sound
like
interim study
representative walner how do you react
i think that sounds like a reasonable
suggestion and
i mean i'm i would personally spend the
time studying it i mean i know sometimes
things get into interim study and they
don't get the attention they need but i
would commit to doing that
so all that's good i the one reason why
i'm not afraid of an interim study is if
if we're the one that's holding we can
control it uh but
um also knowing that the senate version
is making its way through it's not like
this this is the only cowboy standing we
you know we've got the calvary coming
over the hill so
um
okay i understand so
in anyone from the department or or are
you mr head do you have any
you know oh my god don't do that kind of
comments for us because i i think we're
cruising towards an interim study
recommendation
with regard to your last comment i do
believe because we have these two bills
that are
it would be helpful if we dealt with
them all in at the same time so to the
extent the interim study
would keep us from doing this in two
separate forms i think that's helpful i
do think the policy issues are important
so if there's a way of incorporating
children and family law into that
retained or that interim study status i
think that would be helpful but i think
it's the if if
if the thought is to to adopt whatever
the policy issues in this bill into the
senate bill
and and have
have it essentially dealt with through
the
um
at least through the committee of
conference i think that makes some sense
if the desire is to keep it alive you
know we can deal with it in both houses
too
okay so i hear we're not going to break
anything from your perspective uh
uh ms d did totowsky
are we going to break anything if we
interim study this
all right
great
all right i think we're ready to hear a
motion
mr chair
may i say something yes so just
i understand everybody's saying that and
it makes sense the only
thing i might raise since there is this
senate bill is which is a senate
position if we is it there's no house
position in other words they wouldn't be
starting with
from the house's point of view
the underlying
what's in this bill and
i think that should be taken into
consideration as well i mean is going to
be killing it basically because even if
you quote study it you have nothing to
study until after december and by after
december it's next term so um
and it's not clear to me even listening
to um all the uh
uh witnesses
that
even when the quadrennial thing is done
that there's going to be able to the
analysis will be able to be done that's
going to give us any better numbers than
simply
indeterminable because i mean i've been
thinking pretty hard about what it mean
what they would have to go through in
order to come up with something more
determinable and it'd be an incredibly
complex calculation because it's not a
calculation you'd have to know the
situation of every
uh situation currently in their control
and you'd have to know about the ones
and by the way you're using the wrong
figure it was going to twenty thousand
dollars of income not fifteen so you're
going to grossly grow the number of
people that would be considered they
don't know what that would be because
obviously those people aren't in the
system right now so i think that's going
to remain indeterminable for the for the
foreseeable future
clearly the senate bill is coming over
so it's going to be considered one way
or another and i think if we passed this
then the house would have a position so
that when the the either either dies
altogether or the house has a position
so they can actually discuss it with the
senate as opposed we just take the
senate bill whatever that is i've not
actually seen the senate bill thank you
so just a remark on that and then
representative weber uh
i i i'd say two things one if it comes
from the senate one of our committees
presumably child and family law would
would have an opportunity to hear it and
amend it knowing what they wanted to do
with this so so i
i still think we have a road to repair
if that's what we want to do
and then in my experience
even though when the house doesn't have
a formal position because we haven't
adopted something i've still found a
tremendous amount of reasonableness to
listen and to work collaboratively but
representative weber
i was just going to add to that and say
i because i've never sat on a second
committee
i don't know the answer to this but the
house has already adopted the policy
in this
by passing the bill out of the policy
committee so it seems to me that there
is a fairly good
argument that
um
you know that that that the house did
establish a position that they thought
the policy was good
and that what
the
finance committee is doing is
establishing
that we're not sure
what the policy is going to do
to
the various issues that it impacts in
the state budget but that the underlying
policy is as far as i can see the policy
of the house thank you
uh that sounds brilliant to me thank you
uh are there
any other comments uh
if there are no other comments i i think
uh it's time for a motion
where where am i hearing that uh yeah
yes
come on up to the mic please
excuse me thank you
this has been indeterminable and sent
for interim study for the last three
years we went through hb 616 hb228
this topic and i've studied it because i
love it every day has been
kicked down the road several times
already since 2016.
this will be the fifth iteration of this
bill the 431 bill as was was noted is is
actually quite in opposition to this
what the language of this bill is this
bill is the culmination of all the
studies it is the culmination of all the
research that's been done it's been
heavily researched the impact which is
indeterminable
by the as was stated again
by the
department of health and human services
it's indeterminable because of that
number which was stated as eight percent
of people that may receive some funds or
assistance that this is a matching and
then the court costs we addressed that
already this was going to be you know
the new amended version will be up three
years so you're already seeing a net
reduction in cost to the state and
that's very clear and to pass this one
more time down the road
is another year
another year and then this will never
come to terms the effort i think as was
mentioned is to get sb
431 431 together with this and come to
have hopefully they have some offspring
that is is amenable to everybody but to
to send this out for interim study again
is catastrophic what we do know is
determinable is and we've all heard it
stated and it was just the last time
i'll say it
currently
the higher earning parent is in an
indigent state you want to talk about
who needs help that's anyone that's had
child support orders issued since 2018
the higher earner not in it there's no
exceptions to it silva v silva
we heard about the anderson case they
are in the indigenous state that's who's
suffering to pass this down another four
years will extrapolate to another amount
of our population of new hampshire
children without enough clothing without
enough options that's the real thing
this is trying to address it's been in a
room it's been interim studied
for four or five years now
you heard the research so thank you all
right so to clarify my thinking on the
timing i i i don't think we're going to
end this term without
the legislature
handing the governor something to sign
i'm i'm thinking more of a you know
a relay race
where we're waiting for the the person
behind us to come up and hand us the
baton so that we can
wrap it up and resolve it my objective
would be
to get the legislature to agree on this
because i think the compelling argument
is we need to handle the joint custody
situation with the formula
that's that that that's what i think we
have to do
okay so
so if we do interim study this bill that
doesn't mean we're
postponing
action legislative action on the idea
until january we're just waiting to get
these things married up so that we can
do something yes but marriages of two
people of equals and to have one bill
not go to interim study the purpose of
those executive sessions in marrying the
two sb431 and hp 1647 is to have
that
offspring come out but by having 1647
completely wiped off off the
table is is catastrophic all right i i i
hear you i i do hear you because there's
equal equal parts to this both the
legislature and that but both that is
kind of the interim study that will be
the purpose of it having two parties
come together to to come to terms all
right thank you for your input thank you
very much
he's made me think that that octopass is
the way to go just so we get it out of
our hands get get a position that's
established and get to look at what
happens
so i'm just waiting for a motion
i move on to pass
is and that seconded moved in motions um
so uh let's take a roll call on that
everyone understand what we're voting on
this ought to pass on 1647
okay
house bill 1647 the motion is ought to
pass
representative irf yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean yes
representative walner
representative weber
representative woods no
chairman edwards yes
four to three
uh thank you um
so we're we should draft a blurb on that
who wants to draft that blurb
uh thank you representative weiler
um
okay so that that nearly concludes our
our business for the day i i just i just
want to come back to uh one point
um about finance looking at policy
issues um
representative walner uh when we when we
talked about
hb 1642 relative to lead testing we
accepted the the walner
amendment to it and the walnut amendment
reads to me
as though this is all peer policy and
not financial and so
i was perfectly comfortable accepting it
because i think it uh improved the
intent of the policy people and wasn't
fighting them it was just clarifying
would you would you please state your
rationale on on what we did and why we
did that
well we ended up we ended up i thought
the bill was inexpedient
so in the end i mean
yeah we got rid of it the reason i
thought it was because i mean it
maybe had no financial impact on the
state itself but
actually there there were financial
impacts on families for sure
if if they would lose their child care
yeah because they wouldn't be able to
work
okay so there it was an indirect cost to
the state and reduced employment or
something all right
all right
so um so with that
uh i think uh we're wrapped up and so
i will at uh 12
40 or 54 uh close this hearing thank you
this cannabis bill
they want to take and divide up the
revenue
means